- [Narrator] You Ready to go?
- Hey everybody welcome to Episode 325
of the AskGaryVee Show,
and I'm very excited about this episode.
Let's go right into it.
I know a lot of people
watching on Livestream
across all the platforms,
but it's gonna be LinkedIn today,
as we continue testing out LinkedIn Live.
LinkedIn, please put
in your phone numbers,
if you have a question
for my distinguished guest here today.
Marc, I'm gonna allow
you to introduce yourself
in a second, new book is out.
Obviously, I'm real excited about talking
about Netflix and his career,
but I want to get into
a bunch of questions,
because even the first
three and four minutes
of just hanging with
him before we went live,
I think the energy is
gonna be really good,
which is exciting to me
from a content standpoint.
So, Marc Why don't you introduce yourself,
and tell everybody a little
bit about your origin story.
- Sounds good, Gary.
So, Marc Randolph, Cofounder,
first CEO, Netflix,
and now soon to be author,
which is adding something
totally new to my mix.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- Origin story, well I'm
61, so I'm still working out
what my origin story is.
- [Gary] Where were you born?
- I was born just there in Chappaqua,
up in Westchester.
- [Gary] In Chappaqua?
- Yeah, so I'm in New York boy,
at least was for the
first half of my life.
- [Gary] So, what kind of kid were you?
- I was a kid who anytime
I wanted to do something,
my parents said, go for it.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- I'd come home and go
Dad I'm gonna go caving,
and rather than being like, "What are you,
"what are you nuts?"
I got the, "Fantastic,
that sounds really cool."
- [Gary] That's really neat.
- It was really neat.
- [Gary] Where were
you, you an only child,
do you have siblings?
- No, I'm the oldest of three.
- [Gary] Okay, so right off the bat.
You know it's funny,
you hear that a lot more
from a third child's perspective.
So, even as the oldest, your
parents gave you some room?
- Yeah, I think for
third child, it's like,
what's your name?
- [Gary] (laughs) Yeah, I know, yep.
- No, it was it was really great,
and other thing, I do reflect back on
what was it about how I grew up,
that maybe gave me some
of the things I have?
But one is that, it was also a family
where no was always just
something to get around.
It was not something that
you took no and left.
- [Gary] from the standpoint
of, if your parents said no,
they appreciated you
trying to figure it out?
- A little bit.
- [Gary] 'Cause my mom was
like that a little bit.
Yeah, and also them kind of recognizing
that whenever a barrier came up,
it wasn't like we give up and walk away.
It was always being said.
We can make an amazing example.
- [Gary] Go, go right into it.
- This a little bit later.
This is as I was graduating college,
and I wanted to get a job
as a advertising exec.
I was really into.
- [Gary] I get it.
- Anyway, I applied
for this job at NW Air,
which is no longer here, a big firm,
and it was one of those jobs
which only usually goes to MBAs.
This is an an undergraduate,
so it was a long shot thing,
and there was like, I don't
know, 1,000 people applying.
I got through the first round,
and then the second round,
they bring you to New York,
and I got through the second round.
The third round they bring you back,
and I got down to the point
where there was only four
people applying for this job.
It was like this, holy shit,
and I went in and interviewed
with everybody, whole day,
and didn't get it, and
went slinking back up
to Upstate New York to college.
Then I'm going, well screw
it, I'm not gonna give up.
So I wrote these long emails, or letters.
- [Gary] Letters.
- Letters to everybody, and
basically was saying, all right.
- [Gary] You fucked up.
- All right, I'm gonna try again.
What could I do better?
What should I learn?
What do you want to see,
and then the guy goes,
"Come on down."
Brings me up and offers me the job,
and the crazy thing is, that
no one was given the job.
None of the four of us.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- This was a job which was about
turning a no into a yes,
and so they said no to everybody,
and waited to see who would
not take no for an answer.
- [Gary] Really?
- Absolutely.
- [Gary] That's amazing.
- Isn't that a crazy, crazy thing?
- [Gary] I love it.
- Yeah, so that really is probably
the best articulation of how I grew up.
- Interesting, so you took that job?
- [Marc] No, I didn't (chuckles).
- I kind of actually, notice
how I just set that up?
I kind of, the way you
were telling the story,
I'm like, he didn't take the fucking job.
- I didn't, I took an even crazier job.
- [Gary] Which was?
- There was a guy, I haven't
eve told this story before.
there was a guy in Memphis, Tennessee,
owned a big cotton company, sold it,
been in the family for 200
years, made a gazillion dollars,
and was basically driving around
throwing money out the window, basically.
- Feels like today.
- There you go, and he
bought these properties.
I'm kind of an outdoorsy guy,
I've always been into like climbing
- [Gary] Yeah, your story was caves.
- Yes, absolutely.
- [Gary] I was like, whoa.
- This guy had bought a ski shop,
he had bought a place out in Vail,
and he was looking for something
to tie them all together.
He goes, you're gonna run this
big co-marketing business.
- [Gary] Did you know him
through family, friends?
Because there's no way
that somebody like that
would give you that at bat
at that young of an age,
unless there was some other
variable relationship.
- Gary, you're dragging me down
to these complicated
stories, but you're probing.
So, there's an organization.
- I apologize, and this where I want
to bring value to the audience Marc.
Here's why?
The reason I'm probing is because
I have a very good sense of my audience,
and ironically, I'm pretty good at this,
other than the fact I love
to interrupt all the time,
because I already know
what the answers are,
and because I'm usually on a time crunch.
So, the audience gets mad at me,
because I interrupt everyone.
On the flip side, I
have an incredible sense
of what stories could bring value.
I promise you, Marc, let me tell you
one thing about this audience.
This is not The Today Show.
What's amazing about this audience,
is 34 people, arbitrary
number, just heard that story,
and literally in the next 24 hours,
are gonna reply to a no,
and one of them is gonna get a yes.
You and I, literally right now,
just changed the course
of somebody's life,
and that's what gets me high.
- It's unbelievable, and by the way,
don't worry about the interrupting.
I mean, if you just said,
like pass the rolls,
I would have thought
I was sitting at home.
- [Gary] I love it.
So go ahead, so tell me
about the story then.
How'd you get to him?
- So, when I was 14, my parents
packed me off to Wyoming,
to do this backpacking
trip in the mountains.
- I apologize again.
Which one of your parents was
super outdoorsy, if either?
- My dad, my dad.
My dad grew up in Austria, so
he kind of had this whole--
- [Gary] Interesting, kept going.
- So, and then I loved this program,
and it was a program
that teaches leadership,
using wilderness, as a setting.
I was a student there for
three or four summers,
and then I ended up
teaching there as a leader,
and then eventually
got I got to the point,
where I was leading
leading the whole courses.
So, a lot of responsibility young.
That was my college summer job,
and so this Julian Jay Hillenburg, III,
the guy with the cotton company,
one of the things he did when
he was throwing the money
out the window was, "I'm
gonna take a course."
He went out to Wyoming,
he did this course.
- You taught it?
- I did not, but he was so enamored.
- [Gary] By the course.
- And the instructors, that when he heard
through someone else that I
was a course leader there,
he goes, "I want that guy."
- You know what's so funny, I to this day
still have that in me.
You show me a kid, a guy
or gal who flips sneakers,
sells blow pops, does cards,
I believe in that shit.
- You know what the genetic
marker is for entrepreneurship?
- [Gary] I do not.
- It's candy arbitrage,
almost everyone I meet,
like you said, it's the same thing.
It's going in and buying it for 10 cents,
and the next day you go
to school for a buck,
and people see that.
- It's why I love people that sell weed.
Like if you tell me that you sold weed
from a bad neighborhood,
obviously, normally,
but not always, and you sold nickel bags,
I already am interested in you,
because it means you literally
arbitraged dime bags.
Well, this is somebody
who's never smoked weed
telling the story, but
Mount Ida College taught me,
but I always thought my friend Rob Muse
would have been a good entrepreneur,
because he had the
discipline and the grind
to go down to the nickel bag level.
That takes a real fucking commitment,
and so, arbitrage in any way.
- Absolutely right, it's the vision
to go knock it out.
It's seeing a an opportunity,
it's seeing a pressure differential.
- [Gary] 100%.
- And that happens for kids
who are six, when it's candy.
It happens for people
when they're 26, or 46,
when they see, oh man, taxis suck.
I'm gonna do.
- [Gary] A hundred thousand percent.
- That's why it's such a marker for that.
It's someone who sees those things early,
matched of course, with
all these other things,
that you've seen, which is that.
- So that's what happened,
you're a kid at a school, you're 22?
- [Marc] Yeah.
- And you're now running this conglomerate
of different businesses.
- And then even worse, I did this job.
- Or better.
- For six months.
And this company, yeah better,
the company that one of
the properties was in,
in kind of a ghost town
resort, outside of Vail,
and the manager left, and
I go, I want that job.
So, they moved me out, and
now, you have this 23-year-old,
who knows nothing, and
he's running this place
which has 60 employees, and has
these huge cash flow issues,
and a restaurant, and a
bar, and then I'm going down
I'm doing the marketing,
and the advertising,
and it was like cash flow
101, it was management 101,
it was thrown into this super
deep pool and going, swim.
- No, no, I get it Marc.
I'm sitting here quiet, because I'm like,
oh my God, we grew up the same way.
By the way, I'm the byproduct
of the same thing in a liquor store.
It was a small base of like
four, or five, six employees,
and then I grew it, but by
the time I was 25 years old,
I had managed people,
I had paid all my bills
with my own cash flow, no
credit, no credit line.
Forget about fucking raising
capital, no credit line.
The first business I built from $3 million
to $60 million a year,
in fucking eight years,
had no credit line.
- You see, that's awesome
because then you don't see credit
as a crutch, you see
as, it's a thing to use,
but you know now how to use that.
Otherwise, it's awesome.
- Even if you're trained in it,
when I raised money for Empathy,
I didn't spend it as well.
- That's exactly right.
It's something that could
state, you overspend,
you're out of business.
And that is a very, very strict teacher.
So I mean, yeah, these
were cool things, yeah.
- So you did that, you learned some stuff.
- Did that, and then it got,
probably the job which
influenced me the most,
is that I got this weird job.
- Can I ask a quick question,
that I think a lot of
people struggle with?
So you're 23, and you're
in this resort town, right?
- [Marc] Yes.
- Ski resort town?
- Sort of, it's halfway
between Vail, and Steamboat,
which means the middle of nowhere,
but it's close to both.
- And you're 23?
- [Marc] 23.
- And you've got this cool, big job.
- [Marc] Yep.
- How did you balance your personal life,
and your professional life,
at that point in your life?
Because, I'm actually, I'm not
gonna even lead the question,
what did you do?
How much did you date?
How much fun were you having?
How much not fun were you having?
- It's a great thing.
It was a really good lesson.
I had a lot of fun, so don't get me wrong,
because everyone who was
working there was 23.
- [Gary] That's where
I was going, go ahead.
- Yeah, and it was--
- [Gary] And you were the
alpha of the 23-year-olds.
That was leverage.
- That was the bad part, though,
was that these guys, it was on the banks
of the Colorado River, so they'd all go,
hey we're all going rafting,
and I'm going I've got to
do, you know, inventory
or I gotta pay bills.
I had these responsibilities,
and it kind of really was painful.
So, I got a lot of fun,
so I'm not bemoaning it,
but there was this realization
that there's a different level
of responsibility that I had.
But I did meet my wife there,
and so something amazing
did come out of that.
- That's awesome, go ahead.
- All right, so come
back east and got this.
- [Gary] How old?
- Must have been only 24.
- Oh, so you were there quick.
- [Marc] 25, two years in
Colorado, two and a half years.
- Okay, keep going.
- So, come back and got this crazy job,
basically as a gopher to the CEO
of a music publishing company.
I think my title was like,
Chief of Staff or something.
- The reason I'm looking
at all these guys,
is like, literally, so far,
I just want everybody who's
listening to you right now.
I'm sorry Marc, I'm
taking this episode over.
Everyone who's listening, I just,
I don't know if you've been listening,
but I think I could see
some of you in the room
putting the pieces together.
My core advice is to do, and manage,
and actually make and sell,
and/or if you want to be somebody,
go work as an admin, a
gopher, a chief of staff
for somebody that's extremely
at a very high level,
eat shit is basically what I'm saying,
basically is what I'm saying,
and I'm just gonna make it simple here.
So far what I've heard from you Marc
is the first two things
he did in his career
was jumped in full throttle,
sacrifice is what he was saying,
couldn't have as much
fun, dealt with all that,
was practical, and then,
and then had the humility,
let's say it one more time
for all the people out there
that love being a CEO, had the humility
to go from being the lead
dog of something like that,
you know, in that ecosystem,
to then going and being a
gopher, a chief of staff,
or whatever we're about to hear,
and I just want to remind all of you,
this all led for him to be the
Cofounder and CEO of Netflix.
Keep going Marc.
- I'm so glad you called the
little time out on that one,
because that is the piece of advice
I give to every single person who goes,
I want to come out to Silicon Valley.
I want to be an entrepreneur.
Blah, blah, blah, what should I do,
and the answer is really simple.
You find the smartest person
who will take you seriously,
and do anything they ask.
The end, that's it.
- [Gary] Just get close to the sun.
- Absolutely right,
watch, and I got this job.
- [Gary] You're shaking your head, right?
Because now you're thinking about McGee.
It's fucking the game.
- [Marc] It's a such a simple thing,
and people get all hung up on their ego.
- 'Cause their ego's insecure.
- [Marc] I have a degree
in this, I should be.
- Nobody gives a fuck about your degree.
It's 2019, nobody gives a fuck.
- [Marc] Or what your SAT is.
- SATs, isn't it like 2400 now?
They fucking changed that shit.
Nobody even knows what
the fucking rules are
about SATs anymore.
- It's crazy.
It's just you gotta do stuff,
and you got to see how people
who know how to do it, do it.
It's the combination of those two things.
- So what, some use it?
Tell me, I'm like.
- It was it Music Publishing Company,
so it had rights, publish
sheet music, books,
administered music rights,
that kind of stuff.
- [Gary] What the guy's
name, or the gal's name?
- The guy's name was Loren
Kaiser, believe it or not.
- What do you want, like old school dude.
- Yeah, a little bit, but you
know I thought my job was.
- Was he rough?
- Yeah, absolutely, he
was kind of a street guy,
'cause he had music, you know?
- Give me one ridiculous story.
Give me something ridiculous that happened
the first six months that you were there?
So you got there, and
your were a little bit
Colorado chill now, and you get back
into the East Coast speed,
and here's fucking Loren from the streets.
- It was pretty intense,
because it was lots of yelling.
- [Gary] Well that's where
I thought you were gonna go.
- That was the hard part about it.
I mean, you saw how
this guy treated people
at all different levels.
- [Gary] At all levels?
- Yeah, like you'd see how
he dealt with this person,
or the talent who came in.
He was nice to them, and it
was like a real disconnect.
- [Gary] He was nice the talent,
that shitted on the help?
- Yes.
- [Gary] I understand.
- And it was kind of a weird thing.
- [Gary] No it's not a weird thing,
it's how fucking a lot of people did it,
and that's why I would do the reverse.
- Right exactly, you kinda
really form this thing.
There's this guy, oh
God this is a good one.
I haven't told this story
either, so these are good.
So, this guy was the production manager,
okay the guy was in charge of
getting the books out on time.
Unbelievable asshole, I mean, seriously.
This is a true story.
One time when someone was called up,
and said we're gonna miss my deadline.
He goes, you're not
gonna miss the deadline,
and he sent them a little package.
It had a razor blade, a
rubber band, and a dixie cup,
and he sent it to them and
said, "If this is late,
"I want your balls in that cup."
I'm going Jesus, I'm going, oh my God.
- [Gary] That's a surprise and
a delight in a different way.
Okay, and.
- But the weird thing is,
everyone liked this guy.
Every morning, hey Frank,
hey, good morning Frank,
how was your weekend Frank?
- So, I'm going, what is wrong with me?
Why do I hate this guy?
Why can I not stand this guy,
and everyone else seems to like him?
Then of course, what
happens is, he gets fired,
and as soon as he's gone.
- [Gary] Everyone hates him.
- Oh, what an asshole,
and that was another
huge revelation for me, of seeing,
I call it, of realizing
that my judgment is okay.
- [Gary] I understand.
- That if I think someone's in.
- [Gary] How long did you last
as chief of staff?
- Oh, that job?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Marc] Not long,
because what happened is.
- [Gary] You didn't like the culture.
- No, I stayed at the company,
but part of it was, he had all
these different businesses,
and one of them was a mail order division.
Now we're getting into
the big intersection
between you and me.
- Yes, go ahead.
What year is this, paint me a picture.
God 1985 or 1986, so, but
the mail order division,
is in the back of all the songbooks,
is a little line of type that says,
For a list of more great
Cherry Lane songbooks,
send a self-addressed stamped envelope to,
and my job, and I say
that for God knows why,
I want that job, I told them.
- Because you could have autonomy.
- Yes, and then so my job at first was.
- [Gary] I just want to remind everybody.
We're really getting better here.
Now that I understand Marc's framework,
you could see how easy that was.
I'm sure a lot of people are watching,
and literally were just
like, how did he know that?
I know that because once I
understand somebody's framework
to the world, which we clearly
have a very similar one,
it's very easy for me to understand that,
and it's also where all the
opportunity is right now.
If you're working somewhere.
What's great about
entrepreneurship is, it's autonomy.
What's great about being an executive,
who has deep entrepreneurial tendencies,
but for whatever reason is
currently not an entrepreneur,
is the ability to see the
arbitrage where there is autonomy.
Usually, where nobody's
paying attention to,
usually where there's no money yet.
- If you wait 'til it's
obvious, it's too late.
That's part of it.
So, anyway, I went into this business,
which is xeroxing the list of
more great trailing songbooks,
and sticking it in the
self-addressed stamped envelope,
and then going the warehouse
and fulfilling the orders.
I loved that.
- Why do you think you
had so much humility
to take on these jobs?
Go deep with me, not surface level.
Why intuitively deeply, do
you think you had the ability
to have humility, because
I believe humility,
has been my deepest
advantage on the market?
It's not the one that's obvious.
- I don't really care
what people think of me,
but I think that's looking back.
I think for the first 10 years,
I didn't even realize that was it.
I didn't really care what
people thought of me,
and so I was following my
intellectual curiosity,
without going through the
filter of how will this look?
Or, you know what I mean?
- Yes, I do know what you
mean, keep going with it.
- I think that's part of it,
and this is fascinating,
for some weird reason.
- [Gary] Intuitively, like
there's something here.
- Direct marketing, all of a sudden we do
color list of songbooks, with photos,
and now it's a brochure,
and then it's a catalog,
it's a mailing.
- [Gary] Did you love the feedback?
- Oh my God.
- [Gary] Was that feedback the addiction?
- Unbelievable.
- [Gary] 'Cause that's what
it was for me at first,
when I think back to marketing.
- Sure.
- What if I do this, what will happen?
It was almost scientific.
- [Marc] And avoiding
all the all the argument.
Oh no, it should be red.
No, it should be blue.
- Full autonomy.
- [Marc] I know for sure.
I know red is .274% better than blue.
- But you knew that after the fact.
- [Marc] Yes, of course, that's
the beautiful thing of it.
- Well that's having humility
to being okay with being wrong.
Like the other day, I posted
an Instagram post upside down,
the video's upside down.
It did not do well.
I fucking am so happy you don't even know.
I hypothesized that it might do well.
I wanted it to do well,
but nothing gets me more
excited than when the market
says to me, hey tough guy,
you think you're so fucking
good after 25 years,
eat this, Dick.
(Marc laughs)
I love that, I love when
the market does that to me.
- It would be upsetting if all of a sudden
you got the same response
upside down as right side up.
That would really say something.
- Well, to me it's like breaking behavior.
How do you break through?
So anyway, nonetheless.
- Okay, so direct marketing,
so it turns into that.
I built this thing up into
like a mail order division,
really pretty substantial.
Then the next big break was,
this music company goes, they
want to start a magazine.
We're gonna start a guitar
magazine, with sheet music in it,
and they're all clamoring
for the editorial positions,
'cause everyone there is into music.
They're going, who's going
to do the circulation?
It's like one of those,
everyone take one step forward,
and they all step backwards.
It's like I'm going, I don't know
how to do magazine circulation.
And I learned, taught
myself magazine circulation,
which is subscriptions,
subscription marketing,
how that whole business works.
Launch the magazine.
- [Gary] What was the magazine?
- Called Guitar.
- [Gary] Yeah, I've heard of it.
- Pretty big, pretty good one.
Yeah, successful.
Then I got recruited away from there
to help start a computer
magazine called Mac User.
Went to Mac User, and again
doing all the circulation work.
We sold Mac User to Ziff Davis.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- Launched a mail order company.
I want this one.
Now, each time I'm getting more and more
toward being the alpha of these things.
Then they put me in charge of
launching a mail order company
called Mac Warehouse, and Micro Warehouse,
a big mail order company.
Yeah, and that went
public, but before then,
I got the next big break,
which is ended up getting
hired to turn around
a mail order company
in Carmel, California.
Off my wife and I go to Carmel,
assuming it's an expat type of assignment.
In other words, I'm an East Coast boy,
and you get to California,
you're going, this isn't so bad.
- The weather can trick you every time.
- [Marc] Especially Carmel,
which is spectacular.
- Wine country, and all that, go ahead.
- So, I turned the company around,
and we sold it to a company back here.
My wife and I are looking
at each other going like,
I'm not sure we want to go back to there.
The thing is in Carmel, which
it's right on the coast,
but it's kind of South.
There's nothing around it,
so there's no jobs south,
no jobs, west, east rather,
certainly no jobs west,
the ocean's there.
So it's go north, young man,
and I ended up getting a job at a company
called Borland International,
with this fleet con guy
that I mentioned earlier, was CEO.
This was old-fashioned software.
Everything was sold in a
computer store, all retail.
- [Gary] Right, in a box.
- No downloads obviously, no mail order.
- [Gary] I remember it.
- And I saw the arbitrage.
I go, this is nuts.
I knew all this stuff about mail order.
I knew catalogs, I knew how
this was gonna, direct mail.
I'd mailed a gazillion
pieces of direct mail,
getting these magazines launched.
I go, this is crazy, and
convince them to hire me
to do their direct marketing,
and that took me longer.
I was at Borland almost seven years,
but it took me four years to bring that
to almost 40%, 45% of all
their sales was direct sales.
Huge, huge thing, buried the earth.
Okay, a foot deep in mail order pieces
for software, but unbelievable.
That was the next transition.
There's a the theme of all this stuff.
It's like falling uphill.
They needed someone to run one
of their software divisions.
I was in this marketing
group, so I was with sales,
and they go, can you run
this as a general manager?
That put me really into the tech business,
because then I had
programmers working for me,
and I had the full responsibility
for bringing out a product,
and that was the transition
into being much more
into general management
in the tech business,
learning how software was made,
learning all those pieces.
We sold off my division,
and then ended up,
we're almost here.
Ended up, we sold off that division,
and I went to work for a small
startup called Visioneer,
which made scanners, which was
the most dysfunctional place,
even more than the music publishing place.
The most dysfunctional
place, because the CEO.
- Everything stems from the top.
- [Marc] It does.
- You could have a two person
company that's dysfunctional,
if she or he is an idiot.
- He just wouldn't make a decision,
didn't let people have fiefdoms,
and fight with each other.
It was the only job,
my wife has since said,
that she could tell I did not want
to go to work in the morning.
- [Gary] Interesting, makes sense.
How long were you there?
- About a year, about 15
months and I got fired.
So, second time in my
life I've been fired.
- They did you a huge fucking favor.
- Yeah, absolutely.
You're telling me, and
then I went to work.
I overcompensated, and went to work
for two very good friends of mine,
starting a small software company.
I say overcompensated,
because it was great
working for my friends.
- I understand what you're saying.
- It was a really geeky software company.
He was making tools for
quality assurance engineers.
- At that point, after
that 15 month experience
it was nice to go somewhere safe.
- Oh my God, absolutely.
- I understand.
- I had to be with people
I liked and enjoyed.
- [Gary] I'm a big fan of what you did.
- This other thing, as a marketing person,
I kind of have always wanted to understand
and like my product, and I
couldn't empathize that well
with people who did quality assurance,
but you teach yourself.
- The great gift of my
life, is I've never sold
anything I don't believe in.
I just refuse to.
I'm not good at it.
- [Marc] That's the thing.
- I suck at selling.
I'm great at talking about
the shit I fucking believe in.
- That's it, I totally
agree with you Gary.
That's really cool.
- Keep it going.
- So, anyway, that's what led,
because that little software company
that I was with these
two other guys starting,
we had 12 people, and we got
sold to a big software company,
called Pure Atria, which was a company
which had been founded and was being run
by a gentleman named Reed Hastings.
- That was a good transaction for you.
- Absolutely right, 'cause those guys
all got banished to the
basement to be a business unit.
I was put in as the head of marketing,
because he needed a marketing person.
So I began working directly for Reed.
- [Gary] When?
- This was 1996, or 1995.
- And thus began your relationship?
- And luckily, not just working for Reed.
Reed and I found out we
lived in the same town,
and so we began commuting
to work every day,
and formed this friendship.
Then, the real break was that
six to nine months later,
Pure Atria was acquired, and
unlike the last transition,
which was great, investors all made money,
and we all got to keep jobs.
This one the investors made money,
but Reed and I were gonna get fired.
- I understand.
- Or made redundant,
as the expression goes.
I said, awesome, I'm
gonna start a company.
- [Gary] You were ready.
How old were you at the time?
- 38, 37, 38, something
like, I'm bad a math.
- [Gary] You were ready.
- Oh I was ready, and I'd kind
of had these responsibilities
of starting companies within a framework.
I knew what I wanted to
do, because I had all this,
I had 20 years of direct
marketing experience,
I had circuit subscription.
I knew a lot of these pieces,
and I saw it the internet,
that this was direct response on steroids.
This was catalog done to a level
that no one could imagine.
- I remember, when I launched
winelibrary.com in '96,
the entire wine business,
at the highest level,
the K&Ls, the Zachys, Sherry-Lehmanns,
who I aspired to, defeat
their entire infrastructure
was uncataloged, and I remember vividly,
the first time I saw the internet in '94,
and I was like, I've got them.
I literally thought that.
- [Marc] Absolutely, and every
month they missed the boat,
you're going like.
- And they missed the boat
until the early 2000s.
- (laughs) Yeah I know, isn't that nuts?
- That's the beautiful
part of people being high
on the way they did it.
People hold on, it's happening right now.
It's why half my audience
is not going on TikTok
right now, because they made
it on Instagram, or YouTube.
- Yeah, we should talk about that later.
It's a big dynamic about
people wanting to lock into
the past, and being unwilling
to transition to the future.
- When it's all said and done,
it's one of the biggest ingredients
to why you and I have
had professional success.
I do not demonize the future,
and we do not put the past on a pedestal.
- And we're willing to
walk away from the past,
no matter how good and
comfortable the past is.
- I'll spit on the fucking past.
Ready for this, not only
will I spit on the past,
I'll spit on the past
that did right by me.
I built Wine Library on the
back of email marketing,
on the back of direct
mail, on the back of print,
on the back of radio.
It was later that social emerged.
I will shit on social one day.
I only care about the consumer,
and whatever she or he
is doing is my religion.
There is nothing else.
- You know, it is so funny,
because you put us in the same category.
You and I see this so clearly,
and you can tell people,
here is how it works.
- My friend, it's built on
self-esteem and humility.
That's why we see it.
- [Marc] It's weird.
- Here's why, whenever
our timing has been off,
has been when we micro failed.
Our game is predicated on timing.
When you see it, you have
to get your timing right.
- Yeah, yeah, right.
- I'm a better executive today
than the 21-year-old version of me,
because I understand timing better.
- Yeah, yeah that's right, right, right.
- [Gary] Right?
- And you see more patterns,
you're getting better at all those things.
- That's right.
- Yeah, that's cool.
- But because we've had micro failures,
because we were there too early,
because it's never too late,
because we don't we don't
put that on a pedestal.
We can only be too early.
- [Marc] Right, right, right.
- Right?
- Yeah, absolutely, sure.
You can be too early.
- Correct, so, we are
only vulnerable to that,
and thus when we've micro failed,
it's been predicated on that.
Thus, we had to be able
to deal with judgment.
- [Marc] Right, right,
right, right, right.
- The reason people like the
past is because it's safe.
Nobody gets fired for buying
commercial and marketing right now.
- (chuckles) Yeah, well said.
- Let's get to this part.
My entire ecosystem around me is stressed,
because I'm super behind.
Talk to me about the book.
Actually, we need talk
about Netflix for a second.
You're right on the cusp.
I can't pull the rug out from that.
- That was absolutely a fantastic intro,
because what we've done is led this,
right up to where the book picks up.
which is where Reed and I are in the car,
driving back and forth in this period,
we're waiting for the deal to close,
nothing really to do,
and going, what next?
- [Gary] And you're brainstorming.
- And we're brainstorming,
because I'm going,
I'm starting this company.
Reed's not, he's gonna go
off and reform education,
but he wants in.
He says, "I'll back you,
"and I'll be on the board.
"Go off and do this,
but we need the idea."
That really is where where
that will never work kicks off,
is us brainstorming
ideas, and stupid ideas.
You know like personalized baseball bats,
and customized dog food,
and shampoo deliveries.
- All predicated on this
model of delivering it.
Internet, and delivering
it physically, I got it.
- [Marc] And personalization.
- And personalization.
- Which is my other big theme.
So, we were looking at this category,
and then, it's this crazy
nut, like Jeff Bezos
has this weird idea about
selling books, books.
So, we're going what are
the other big categories,
and video sales $8 billion category,
but I go, Bezos is gonna take one.
- Were you were you the CEO,
when Blockbuster passed
on buying Netflix, or no?
- [Marc] No.
- That was after?
- Yeah, that's back when we Reed and I
were running the company together.
- Understood, I love shit like that.
I don't know if you know this.
I don't know if you knew that Yahoo
bought both Google and
Facebook, and both deals died.
- Really?
- Really.
- I did not know that.
- So, I always think about the what ifs.
- I was thinking that
should be one of those
special interactive TV specials,
where you can hit this
button and see what happens,
if Blockbuster did buy us.
- You know that that is my
dream of what heaven is.
My core dream of heaven,
is being able to see scenarios
play out that didn't.
The reason I'm never
scared to make a decision,
is I know you'll never
know the alternative.
- [Marc] Right, right, right.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- So, to me, my Nirvana mindset
of what heaven could be, is
the idea of gonna heaven,
and then be, like, this is the one
that I always think about.
So I'd be like, okay heaven machine.
I sit down, like fuck
I'm so pissed I died.
All right, fuck it, let's
move on to the chapter.
That's literally how I picture it,
literally how I picture it.
I'm like, all right fuck it,
let me start enjoying the new thing.
Fuck it, it's over, I died.
So, I would say all right
heaven, first question.
Show me the draft pick that
the Jets should have taken
that would have led to them
to actually winning a Super Bowl.
Right, and then you see it play out.
The biggest one for me
that I always think about.
Heaven, show me when I would have died
from a horrific accident had
I not done something weird
like went back and forgot my keys,
and thus, that threw off the timing,
and the tree would have fell on me,
or when I took that flight,
and had I stayed here,
I would have choked on
that bone at dinner.
I don't think people understand.
This is what fascinates
me about decision-making.
People think it's binary.
They're like, oh which job or university,
or what start.
- [Marc] It doesn't make
that big of a difference.
- It's so complex.
- Yeah, it's just one
little one little choice.
It's not gonna set your whole life path.
You have control over those things.
- I talk about it all the time.
So, that's what this book's about.
- So, this book is about two things.
It's the untold story.
It kind of reveals that it's not just.
- I don't know this at all.
Where are your and Reed's
relationship right now?
- [Marc] Great.
- Great, awesome.
- Really good, still socialize together.
We talk all the time.
I mean, we had a really--
- 'Cause I would have a lot
empathy to write this book,
in the white heat moment
of Netflix right now.
We're still right in the epicenter.
I'm actually, genuinely curious.
It's almost be like if
my brother right now
wrote the book of Vayner
Media, like we're still in it.
I always think it's a lot easier
to talk about shit when it's over.
So, I guess my real question is,
was there anything you wrote in there
that you were like, oh man I hope Reed
is okay with me saying this?
Did you have him read it?
I actually am very curious
about how you write this book right now.
- Both, both of those things
which is, I said to myself,
I have to be honest and vulnerable here,
about myself, because
there's a lot of stuff
that I didn't do well, a lot
of things I made mistakes.
- [Gary] Of course, of course.
- Because the whole point of the book,
is to show that someone
can make a dream come true,
but it's really to say
how, so that someone else
can see these things and
go, I think I could do that.
Not start a company, not become,
but take any idea they have.
- [Gary] And execute.
- And execute, that's what I wanted,
and to do that I have to
show that I'm not superhuman.
I don't make miraculously
always the right decisions,
it's an approach.
I did the same thing with Reed.
He is a real person, not this
super CEO, and it was done--
- Did you go up front and say,
hey, I'm thinking about writing this book,
and if I'm gonna do it, I'm
gonna be super transparent
about it and thus, I'm gonna
talk about my shortcomings,
but are you okay with me going there
because he's still in it?
- Yes, and we talked a bunch about it.
It was one moment where I--
- I mean, I think about, I apologize,
but I think about my brother coming to me,
and I'm just like, I
want to write this book,
and I'm like, cool.
Where my where my body goes,
like bro, can't you just wait,
because while I'm still in
it, you're fucking with it,
while I'm in it.
Whereas, when it's over.
I mean, I've been able
to share so much more
about Wine Library, since I'm out of it.
I mean, there's so much
I still want to share
about to my audience,
that I can't just yet,
because if I do, it fucks me up,
because I'm actively fucking driving
this boat still right now.
- Absolutely true, and it took distance.
I could have written this when I left,
because I left in 2003, so 16 years ago.
- Yeah, that's fucking nuts.
- So, it took that much time
for me to get some distance,
because I had to realize
all the things that I did,
not just at Netflix, but
at the previous companies
What were the ones that
were not just happenstance.
Marc can I ask you a question.
- [Marc] And what were
the ones that worked?
- 'Cause this is really,
this is a really interesting question.
I believe that I talk a
lot about creating clarity,
and the fact that I owned
nothing of Wine Library,
because I thought it was
important to help the audience.
But there is an absolute
truth to the fact that
there was a certain time in my career,
that I didn't want to create that clarity,
because there was a level
of, that's who I was.
Like I was a owner of Wine Library.
I didn't want to give up that truth,
because otherwise I had
nothing, 'cause I restarted.
If I'm being fair with myself,
I didn't create as much
clarity of me owning nothing,
and building it for my parents.
Now, it's this noble act, but
for three or four years there,
were I didn't create clarity, I needed it.
I had my own level of insecurity,
even though I'm never that insecure.
Let me ask you a question, I apologize.
- [Marc] Oh, sure.
- But I want to ask you a
very deep question for me.
How are you dealing with, it's been 16.
I think I'm only even
asking you this question,
because of the vibe you gave me
by saying it's been 16 years.
It must be very tricky to be the Cofounder
and first CEO of Netflix, in a world
where it is the company that it is now,
which is a very different
iteration of what it was.
How do you balance the
gravitas of such a title,
versus your own internal
mechanism of how much
or how little, which
I have no context for,
of how you feel about where it is today,
being based on your DNA and execution?
- That's an unbelievably good question,
because it is something
that took a long time
to put into context, which is,
I don't want to take credit
for something that's not me.
- [Gary] I believe that about you,
which is why I even felt the courage
to ask you the question I just asked,
which is why I think it's
a super important question.
- Writing the book was fantastic,
because you begin to realize
what we really did accomplish,
and going from zero to
one, what Reed has done
is going from one to 7290,
which is also remarkable.
I recognize every minute
that when I travel someplace,
and everyone wants a selfie
with me because of Netflix,
that's not because of me.
So, the real thing is,
what do you do with that?
- Or calibrating what part of you that is?
- Correct, I'm not gonna
say no, no, no, go away.
I mean, that's what I am saying.
I mean, I am saying,
what do I do with that?
- [Gary] Yeah, that's right.
- I can show up to speak,
and you'll come to hear me,
how do I use that?
- Yeah, and I'll be honest with you,
having it framed up in my
mind of what was gonna happen.
That's actually just not true,
having enough knowledge of what happened
with the company from afar,
it's really interesting where my mind
and heart is going
right now, which is wow,
this guy has so much to fucking give,
because like very much.
You know listen this is me
paying compliment to myself,
so it's not as good of a
compliment as it sounds,
but like, the reality is,
when I see these similarities
that we have, and I know
how valuable they are
to be a conversation, all of a sudden
it's like put me in this happy place,
and I actually asked you that question,
because I actually think it's
the kryptonite potentially
to all the good you can do
over the next three decades.
I think, and just hearing you answer it,
and even the zero to
one, I'm happy right now,
because I believe you have a lot to give
based on what I'm hearing
come out of your mouth
in the origin story,
and I love the fact that you've been able
to calibrate this dragon,
because I think the dragon
could have been the
thing that unwound you.
You know this, because you're
doing the reverse of it.
Do you know how many fuckers run around
and take credit for shit.
I mean, they're not even
remotely close to having
to do with, they happened to like stumble.
There's literally people who
like fucking cleaned the toilet
at Netflix in week one
who claimed to be the CEO.
- Yes, bogus, I agree.
- [Gary] It happens every day.
- Yeah, and it's absolutely
what I did not want that to be.
- [Gary] I believe that.
- And it's it's also saying, it wasn't me.
There's a cast, even the zero to one,
there's a cast of people who
all contributed immensely.
That's what I want people to see.
- [Gary] I believe you.
- Is this how.
Is this A, this is not some
guy who got his MBA, and--
- [Gary] Can I give you
a huge recommendation?
- Of course.
- I highly recommend you
putting out some more content
around this on LinkedIn at scale.
I think you can really help people.
I think there's a lot of people.
- I'm doing my best.
- Who don't have the luxury of you and I,
self-esteem and circumstances,
who create association with success,
that has nothing to do with it.
You know what it's like?
It's like all those Golden
State Warrior and Patriot bands
that run around, that
aren't from those towns,
who need to wear those jerseys,
to think they're successful.
All these fuck face patriot bands Marc,
that are walking around
today proud of themselves,
because they root for a team
that won 43-nothing yesterday, are losers.
Now, you can have pride in your team,
but if you have no
association to the Patriots.
You're not from Boston.
Nobody in your family's from Boston.
My favorite bullshit one,
you didn't go to Michigan,
all these fuck face
from Michigan are like,
well I went to Michigan,
and Brady went to Michigan,
so I'm a patriot fan.
Fuck you, you're from Seattle Dick.
So, all those people, right.
You know, the people from New England,
the people whose parents are familiar,
they can get there a
little bit but like needing
some association from winning
to make yourself feel like a winner,
is the great vulnerability of our society.
- [Marc] Yeah that's that's
a really astute observation,
I agree, wow.
- And I think you, you with this story,
and your DNA is no joke.
So far, I don't know that many people,
but I know a lot of stuff
could have an incredible
impact on this conversation
that I think leads to
a lot more happiness,
and a lot less insecurity, you.
- Yeah.
- I really mean it.
You know, I'm being selfish
about an ambition towards happiness.
A lot of people try to associate
themselves with winning,
that they deep down know
they have nothing to do with.
- Yeah, it's an honesty,
and a vulnerability,
and you got to be able
to do that for yourself,
before you can do it for anybody.
- Where do you live?
I live in Santa Cruz,
California, which is beautiful.
So, I've got it great now.
You know, I don't do it.
I have a slightly different model,
because I work with this
very small number of people,
you know, doing mentoring
for early stage startups.
- [Gary] Did you fuck up
selling shares of Netflix?
Did I what?
- How did you play your selling of shares,
not to go too deep into.
- [Marc] No, (Gary speaking over Marc).
- Let me give you an example.
Let me tell you why I'm asking.
- [Marc] Please.
- Because I think you could
teach people something.
I never sold a share Facebook.
I was a very early investor,
and I never sold a share.
It blows my mind that
I now have more money
than a lot of early Facebook employees,
who sold at $19 a share,
'cause they just wanted the quick liquid.
I've never been in a
position like you have.
I'm always fascinated by executives
that are part of these long tail wins.
Like, by selling one share,
you're leaving money on the table,
and I'm always fascinated
how people play it, not to,
I don't want you to go too deep,
because I don't like to pry.
How did you think about it
strategically along the way?
- Exactly the opposite of you.
- [Gary] Please, go.
- My attitude is nobody knows anything.
- [Gary] Fair.
- I mean, you are lucky with Facebook.
You might have owned shares of Yahoo,
and if you tell me I
can tell the difference
between Facebook and Yahoo.
- No, no, in never say
that, I never say that.
- If you had Yahoo, you would
have lost all your money.
- Yours, I have more empathy for,
because there it was such a substantial
business model shift,
that I was flabbergasted,
and this is where I
can say I wasn't lucky,
because you could see videos of me
as fat Gary during that time,
yelling at people that
Facebook hasn't even started.
Yelling, yelling.
Yours is different, because
it was such a gigantic switch
of a business model.
- Yeah, it's true, but
I have always had faith
in our ability to do those
things we talked about earlier,
which is always leave the past behind,
and evolve, and recognize,
and we did it many times.
- [Gary] We need control.
- I have a whole bunch of
examples when we did that.
I knew this company would do that,
but still, I sold shares continuously.
- That I understand.
I think the question, you
know, the question is,
did you go by the book and
do what a lot of executives
like continuously, or
was there ever a place.
- No, you weren't allowed to
do that back when I was a lad,
because then if you were,
first of all we had the IPO,
and I had, had some reasonable successes.
You know, these magazines we sold,
mail order companies
and all of that stuff.
But this was a different
order of magnitude.
- [Gary] Were you freaking out?
- Yeah, of course I was freaking out.
- Were you like, I can't
wait to six months to sell,
like the unlock.
- No, differently.
- [Gary] Some part of you.
- Yes, but not not for that reason.
I was going, I need to.
This is so different I can't
gamble my family's legacy.
- [Gary] I respect that.
- Because of that, and so, it actually
was two reasons I left Netflix,
and one was recognizing, I'm not.
- [Gary] The guy for this.
- It's too big of a company now for me.
I'm not good at that.
- I get it, I get it.
- [Marc] The other one--
- By the way, real quick I apologize,
I will never be the CEO
of a public company.
I won't, I can't, I'll be terrible at it,
no, no, really bad.
Like, I get on a fucking,
like what do they call it.
When you have an.
- [Marc] Earnings call.
- Earnings call, like the first question.
The first question is
like Gary, why did Vayner
have a bad December?
Like, fuck you, motherfucker.
What do mean, you're asking.
You're a fucking student on Wall Street.
This is real shit, because
I think in four years
this voice is gonna be big,
so I fucking hurt my P&L
because I'm investing.
- (chuckles) That's right,
I am totally with you.
- Yeah, and then all of
a sudden the next day,
Wall Street Journal's like,
Vayner is out fucking Goldman Sachs.
It should be off the board.
The board is like, I'd be
fired within 43 seconds.
- I have a reminder reading folder,
which I look at every month or two,
with things in there I want to remember,
and one of them is a Jeff Bezos letter,
right when they went
public, saying basically,
don't buy this stock if you are looking
for the stock to go up, because I am not,
I promise, running it, so I totally agree.
- That's the counter to why I
think I do want to go public.
I would be like, do not buy a single share
for the next decade, and then
I want to rise like a phoenix
and kill all of you fuckers.
Well anyway, so is the--
- Let's do a couple things.
- [Marc] Yes sir.
- Knowing that I want everybody
who's listening right now
to buy this book, who do you
think this helps the most?
And the books out now?
- Yes, oh tomorrow, tomorrow.
- [Gary] By the time we air tomorrow,
but you can buy it, pre-order it.
- Absolutely, so I'm gonna take.
- [Gary] What's your gut tell you.
- A slightly circuitous
route by saying that,
everyone has heard that
advice, follow your dreams.
Everyone has this idea, they wake up.
It doesn't need to be a business.
It could be something they want to start,
something they want to try.
- The way they want to parent.
- [Marc] Absolutely, right.
- I've been really hot on this,
there's a lot of stay at home parents,
because I've been getting
more into this space,
who's like, you gave me
the courage to homeschool.
You give me the courage to
take my kid out of lacrosse.
He's the only kid not in lacrosse
in this high net worth town,
and it excites me.
I'm like, wait a minute,
this is as much like
entrepreneurship as I thought it was.
Have courage to do what you know is right.
- That's who I think benefits most.
Anybody who has these
ideas, and they're going,
ah, I want to do something but
I but I, fill in the blank,
and I'm going this is the ghetto,
stop the but I crap.
It's not just here's
this step one, step two,
it shows how that thinking works
in building something for real.
- How competitive are you in your own mind
with your own self about
the success of this book?
- Oh, I'm a competitive motherfucker.
- You're like, looking at
the rankings every minute.
You're totally sucked
into the game, right?
- [Marc] But not because.
- No, for the game of it.
- Yeah, the game of it.
So, I don't really, it's not gonna change.
- [Gary] It's not the economics.
- It's not gonna change
my life this second.
- I've written five New York
Times bestselling books.
It's not the fucking economics.
- Everything I do, I
want to do really well.
- [Gary] I understand.
Do you have a friend
who's like a good friend,
who you have this like fun like,
maybe she or he doesn't even know this,
but you have this weird,
like I want to sell.
(Marc laughs)
You do, right?
I fucking knew it.
Give it to me, give it to me.
- No, I'm not gonna tell you this one.
- But at least the abstract would be.
- Other people who've written books,
and I'm like, and they're looking
at your numbers and going.
Oh shit, I'm 6000, and they're like 3000.
Motherfucker, so, but again,
it's because first of all I'd
never published a book before.
And I'm going, part of it is,
how cool is writing the book,
the structures, learning about that.
The other thing is how do
you learn how to sell a book?
And it's this digging in.
- By the way, for my awesome publisher,
you know at Harper, Little Brown,
I'm gonna make a very
simple blanket statement,
that I truly believe.
- [Marc] I know what's coming.
- I know you know what's coming.
How quickly do you learn
that a publisher sells zero
books without your help?
Quickly, next.
- On the advice in my counsel,
I'm gonna take the fifth on this one.
- And, by the way, first
time authors get caught,
because you don't know, you don't know.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean I--
- It is what it is.
- All right, you can
kick me if you have to,
but it's like, I go, why
is the hardcover coming out
before the paperback?
Is that good for the reader?
- Marc, this is not because
I completely run well over,
this is because I don't want
to have this conversation
because I'm gonna jump out the window.
There's nothing that
goes on in publishing,
that makes any fucking sense for 2019,
especially when the framework
is the one that you and I have.
- Yeah, there is some irony,
and I've been in this business,
which overturned this
whole established way
of doing sequencing,
movies, and now I'm back.
- Well you know what's
interesting about book form?
People make fun of me a lot of times,
like Gary, you shit on all this stuff.
Why do you write books?
I'm like, because people read them.
I don't impose my way of
learning on the world,
and I understand that
a lot of people learn
in this format, by their desk at night
four nights, bang through it, on vacation,
like I have no passion.
It's why I put out
content in every platform.
- [Marc] Right, right.
I don't care if you want
to listen to this podcast.
I don't care if you're watching
live right now on LinkedIn.
I don't care if one of the cool snippets,
I want that selling.
I don't sell.
You know, if that becomes the gateway,
like I don't get to judge how one learns.
- Yeah, pretty cool.
- [Gary] Thanks for being on.
- My pleasure, it's been really awesome.
- Thank you, pick up the book guys.
I have a funny feeling
it's gonna bring value.
- Thanks Gary.